COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
I help some cryptocurrency
fans with their Datastore
transaction.
Is it the right time to invest
in the performance market?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Like many start-ups
today, Coin All the Things
is riding the
cryptocurrency wave.
And in order to provide
real-time dashboards,
they mirror all validated
blockchain transactions
back to Datastore
so that customers
can look at historical records.
Sadly though, they
quickly ran into an issue
with their read-write
performance,
being limited to only about
one entity update per second,
far slower than
what they needed.
Thankfully, I was
able to reach out
to some fellow advocates,
who were able to help track
down the problems.
After a few emails
and a couple of hours
of looking at their
tech stack, we
were able to pinpoint
a critical optimization
for their Datastore usage,
transactions and batching.
See, in a hurry to get
their code up and running,
Coin All the Things did
a lot of copy-pasting
from sample references,
and ended up
in a place where
each of their calls
executed as a single action.
And since each request has its
own transactional overhead,
this quickly became
the bottleneck
during high
performance workloads.
The solution, of course, was
to batch these sets of calls
together into a
single HTTP request
so that the overhead is
lowered across the entire set
of updates.
Now, there's two primary ways
to do batching in Datastore.
The first is transactions,
which allow a set of operations
to be atomic.
That is, either the entire
set succeeds or it fails.
There's no chance of half of
the update to have occurred,
which is really helpful when
wanting to enforce consistency
to your observers.
Sadly though,
transactions are only
limited to a set of 25
operations at a time.
This is where the
batching APIs come in.
They don't have the
same size restrictions
and they don't do
updates atomically,
so observers should take
eventual consistency
into account when interacting
with the database.
Now, head to head, we can
see that both transactions
and batching outperform
their linear counterparts.
But to be clear here,
each of these tools
are valuable for a
specific use case,
and shouldn't be
adopted universally
without understanding
the trade-offs.
Now, for Coin All the
Things, the choice was clear.
They split some of their
operations between batching
and transactions, depending
on the consistency model
they needed, and saw
performance skyrocket, along
with their ICO value.
If you'd like to know
more about these topics,
check out the article listed
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of the "Cloud
Performance Atlas"
content, because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]